et
notre invité politique ce matin c'est
jean louis bourlanges bonjour merci
bonjour ou d'être avec nous vous êtes
député modem des hauts-de-seine vous
présidez la commission des affaires
étrangères à l'assemblée nationale et on
est ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
régionale représenté par julien lécuyer
de la voix du nord aujourd'hui bonjour
il ya un bonjour monsieur bourlanges
bonjour et on va commencer en parlant de
l'ukraine jean louis bourlanges 78e
jours de guerre en ukraine et le pays
résiste toujours est ce que pour vous le
crème finira par gagner cette guerre
écoutez ça serait vraiment très
téméraire de ma part de faire un
pronostic militaire ce qui est certain
c'est que par rapport à ce qu'on pensait
initialement l'armée russe a été très
inférieur à ce qu'on pensait qu'elle
était et l'alarmé les forces armées
ukrainiennes la population ukrainienne a
été d'un héroïsme et d'une capacité et
d'une technicité beaucoup plus forte si
bien que maintenant on est dans une
situation de dos relatif équilibre
mais cet équilibre est forcément
précaire c'est pourquoi d'ailleurs nous
tous continuer et nous intensifions
l'aide militaire les occidentaux les
américains les européens parce que la
guerre n'est pas moins intense qu'elle
était elle a simplement changé de nature
on est passé si je puis dire la bataille
de la marne s'il ya une guerre de
mouvement avec des ddd tentative d'un
enveloppement etc qui a été gagné par
l'ukraine comme elles avaient été gagnés
par les français aux 14 à une bataille
de verdun c'est à dire à une
confrontation d'armes et enterré une
lutte pied à pied et ça ça implique des
moyens militaires différents et il faut
absolument soutenir ce bourlanges
l'armée ukrainienne justement vous
parlais justement d'une guerre d'usure
qui était en train de s'enliser qui va
prendre du temps or
la dîmière poutine a des ressources
inépuisables quasi inépuisable en termes
humains et compte sur un essoufflement
du soutien européen
faut-il craindre que sur la longueur
finalement l'europe se
désolidarise il faut bien qu'ils
comptent sur quelque chose parce que
jusqu'à présent monsieur poutine a
compté sur des forces qui n'ont pas
répondu à son attente je crois que c'est
ce que vous dites est très important il
s'agit effectivement de maintenir
intacte la cohésion des alliés la
cohésion européenne et la cohésion entre
les américains et les européens dans le
cadre de l'otan moi je crois que jusqu'à
présent ça tiens le coup c'est difficile
parce que pour les européens pas
tellement pour les français nous avons
toujours été très conscient de la
dimension géopolitique de l'entendre des
européens et pour les allemands c'est
une mutation importante
on voit bien qu'il y à des
contradictions au sein de la coalition
allemande entre une coalition à
tripartite donc difficile à faire
fonctionner avec des verts qui sont qui
sont assez admirable parce que ils sont
pas du tout sur le la ligne pacifiste
traditionnel de beaucoup de verts ils
sont dans la ligne qui a été seul dsk
fischer il ya quelques années qui est
effectivement de lutter pour la liberté
les libéraux allemands sont à même
situation les
les chrétiens démocrates qui sont dans
l'opposition également donc il ya une
meilleure une maturation moi je crois
que nous nous devons effectivement
accepté à un conflit qui est sans doute
d'assez longue durée hélas parce que les
conséquences vont être terribles si ça
dure une conséquence humanitaire et
conséquences alimentaires
les conséquences économiques
il ya un cas et cette guerre ne doit pas
durer il faudrait trouver une solution
si vous craignez que l'unité des
européens se fissure
non ce n'est pas l'unité qui suit sur un
mais il faut effectivement rester
mobilisés on a quand même un peu le
sentiment
je lis que l'on en france en particulier
on peut faire la guerre et la gagner
comme ça moi je cite toujours la phrase
du général de gaulle la vie est un
combat le succès coûte l'effort le salut
exige la victoire effectivement ça
implique des efforts si on il faut
intensifier
l'aller
les sanctions pas les sanctions mais la
dame les mesures d'embargo sur le cas
assez sur le pétrole ans un pic un
certain coût et c'est ça le problème c
est ce que nous sommes capables est-ce
que c'est très bien que nous ne sommes
pas des tigres du bengale un les
européens mais il faut qu'on soit un peu
plus que des chats domestiques ou juste
pardon quand vous dites un coup c'est un
coup aussi pour le pouvoir d'achat des
français ça vous dit il faut l'accepter
c'est un six mois je crois que l'enjeu
de la guerre d'ukraine est essentiel
centrale sinoussi le nous nous arrivons
à aider l'ukraine à préserver son
indépendance sa sauvegarde nous aurons
joué notre rôle historique nous serons
respectés dans le monde nous serons
entendus et nous nous participerons 21e
siècle comme un acteur à part entière si
en revanche nous cédons nounou des
bondons nous nous divisons nous
démobilisons à ce moment là c'en est
fini de
l'influencé européenne du respect des
autres pour l'europe s'en est fini d'où
l'importance des enjeux je pas une
transition mais des enjeux législatif et
des comme des enjeux électoraux en ce
moment où on voit bien qu'on a deux
représentations très différentes d'un
côté madame le pen et monsieur mélenchon
et de l'autre l'ensemble des forces y
compris les sociaux-démocrates
traditionnels et les ricains
traditionnels qui sont ou nous sommes
décidés à défendre nos valeurs à
défendre la liberté à défendre la
souveraineté l'indépendance résultats et
à payer prix il monsieur bourlanges en
effet on reviendra sur les sur
législatives mais une petite question
concernant les
les relations avec les êtres les états
unis on sent quand même que sans
provoquer de fissures réel il y à une
divergence de vue entre l'europe et les
états unis sur la stratégie à conduire
en ukraine les etats unis ont débloqué
une aide supplémentaire de 40 milliards
c'est colossal pour pour aider l'ukraine
mais on sent dans le discours oui qui
cherchent à affaiblir durablement la
russie finalement conduire une politique
presque personnelle vis-à-vis du bloc
russe est ce qu'on doit pas craindre la
une une vraie divergence de stratégique
ne
personnel s'est passé mais vous avez
raison c'est pas mieux le personnel
c'est les américains manifestement la
tentation de reprendre le match rue urss
contre et elle a dit qu'ils ont
j'avais le sentiment d'avoir gagné avec
la fin de la guerre froide et qui qui
est resservie et cela nous sommes dans
une différence d'appréciation alors nous
sommes très très heureux de voir
l'ampleur de la mobilisation américaine
nous savons maintenant que les
américains ne laisse pas tomber les
européens quand même quelque chose de
très très pieux donc je ne parlerai pas
de différend stratégique mais il ya une
différence de 2 objectif final nous
c'est très clair nous considérons que le
but de notre action aux côtés de
l'ukraine c'est de rétablir
l'indépendance la souveraineté la
liberté de l'ukraine ça n'est pas de
remettre en cause la russie les russes
je suis pas du tout satisfait du régime
qu'on les russes actuellement mais c'est
pas nous qui allons changer
c'est une affaire qui sera réglée par
les russes or les américains ont été
effectivement la tentation de rejouer le
match peut-être y at-il des arrière
pensées électorales aussi mais ça tirait
profit de celle mais les amis comment
est ce qu'elles cherchent à tirer profit
je crois qu'ils ont il faut voir d'où
ils viennent ils avaient considéré comme
beaucoup que poutine était un
interlocuteur normal que on allait vers
l'apaisement avec lui
tout c est qu en réalité le véritable
adversaire c'était le président de 6 en
chine donc là et je me rappelle encore
quand je recevais mes homologues baltes
en septembre dernier il était inquiet il
s'était très pro américain et en même
temps il nous disait parce que les
américains ne vont pas nous nous nous
oblige et nous dire écoutez mettez la
douce avec loukachenko et et
poutine car le véritable problème c'est
le problème chinois donc là ils ont
redécouvert le danger le danger russe
ils sont un peu manichéen mais je dirais
moi que il devrait appliquer la doctrine
du regretté président theodore roosevelt
avant la guerre avant la première guerre
mondiale qui disait il faut prendre
avancez vous avec un gros bâton the big
stick et parler doucement à l'horizon au
bâton un etc les carottes pia que vous
évoquez etc mais ils ont pas tendance à
parler doucement forme nous nous
essayons nous avons un bâton beaucoup
moins grand que les américains enfin
nous participons de l'effort de guerre
comme les autres européens avec les
américains et je crois que le président
macron à cent fois raison de dire qu'il
faudra trouver une solution et une
solution qui minimisent l'humiliation de
katyn parce que l'humiliation de poutine
c'est ça qui pousse poutine a une
attitude des régions justement est ce
que cette attitude américaine qui va au
delà de la situation et ukrainienne vise
aussi à affaiblir la russie pour
reprendre votre votre image est ce que
ça va n'est qu'il faut pas arriver avec
un bâton face à un chat un chat et le à
le réduire dans un coin de la pièce au
risque qui vous sautent à la figure
égoutter je crois que le problème c'est
que il faudrait que le ch a lui-même
sache quelle est la sortie qu'ils
imaginent parce que effectivement
poutine s'est mis dans une situation
d'impasse total il n'y a pas d'autres il
a il a quand même il vit dans un monde
parallèle avec une ukraine nazifié tient
pas tout un ensemble de choses qui sont
tout à fait à lui et il ne sais pas
qu'est ce qu'ils proposent qu'est ce qui
prouve justement est ce que twitter est
ce qu'aujourd'hui vous ayez plus clair
je crois qu'il avait je crois qu'il a dû
une vue extrêmement précises au départ
et qu'il n'arrive pas du tout à réaliser
qui était de transformer ukraine en une
seconde biélorussie mais ce qu'ils
voulaient c'est une ukraine qui
ressemble à au pays loukachenko et pao à
la pologne c'était ça son problème alors
il atteint pas du tout maintenant qu'est
ce qu'on peut lui offrir on peut lui
offrir le fait que
une situation dans laquelle l'ukraine
serait ne ne devait pas dans le temps
mais serait dans une situation mais
garantis mais enfin est-ce qu'on
discours il ya déjà sauf à 14 il n'a pas
respecté il faut que l'ukraine soit
comme la finlande il faut finlande
izella d'ukraine
non je crois que la comparaison la
comparaison avec la finlande n'est pas
n'est pas parfaite
mon ami monsieur buzon de l'étang qui
avait été un grand diplomate a rien dit
il faut pas parler de finlandisation
l'ukraine on pourrait inventer le terme
du crédit nation et c'était à la
finlande c'était un accord dans lequel
les finlandais renoncer pratiquement
alors souveraineté internationale pour
garder la maîtrise de leur système
politique
l'anssi scène économique et social
c'était le meilleur compromis possible
aujourd'hui même et c'est pas assez pas
ça c'est pas se partagent la faux pas le
crès n'a pas vocation à être satellisés
par la russie en revanche les les
européens avaient d'inventer un nez une
expression très heureuse qui était que
l'ukraine devait être le voisinage comme
âme de l'union européenne et des russes
alors si monsieur poutine veut
s'acheminer vers sa fin il y aura des
gens nous le président macron en
particulier il y aurait des gens pour
l'aider à faire ce chemin
et je pense que effectivement pour
éviter que le chat que vous décriviez
d'intérieur ne soit prêt à bon vient à
bondir sur n'importe qui et sur sur nous
il faut qui est une solution mais cette
solution pour l'instant elle est très
très loin de l'état d'esprit de vladimir
poutine de la finlande
c'est une bonne chose
relancer un nouveau front est ce qu'il
faut pas craindre la réaction la russie
écoutez moi j'ai eu une longue
discussion avec le président finlandais
qui est venu à à paris quand il a été
voir le podium à qu il est venu dans mon
bureau ce que les présidents de la
république dans ce pays ils ont un
respect instinctif de du parlement ils
ont été voir monsieur monsieur cambon au
sénat ils ont été me voir moi il a été
mieux c'est un personnage extraordinaire
c'est sans doute le dirigeant le
dirigeant européen qui connaît le mieux
monsieur poutine et il est il était
irréfléchi c'est intensément avec
prudence mais détermination à l'entrée
dans de son pays ensuite je suis allé en
finlande j'ai discuté avec le met au
monologue avec l'ailé les
l'administration et les fall en démon
impressionné parce que ils m'ont dit
nous savons que si nous entrons il
rappelle des décomptes aider des risques
les russes peuvent bloquer le golfe de
finlande ils peuvent même pendant
quelques temps bloqué tout que
communication navale ou aérienne sur la
baltique mais nous connaissons les
russes nous nous estimons qu ils
représentent actuellement à danger très
important et donc nous sommes prêts à
assumer nos responsabilités et les
suédois que j'ai vu au même moment sont
dans un état d'esprit voisins moi j'ai
été très très frappés du calme de la
volonté d'unité du sang froid et de la
détermination reste et des peuples
libres de ces deux grandes démocraties
scandinaves et nordiques
autres enfin c'est un sujet qui est qui
dépend et qui interroge le europe vous
avez vu comme moi le président de la
république emmanuel macron qui s'est dit
favorable à la création d'une communauté
politique européenne je le cite pour
mieux intégrer l'ukraine est ce que
c'est une bonne initiative ou est-ce que
c'est simplement un lot de consolation
de l'autre consolation pour le président
et d'un ski non je crois que c'est pas
un lot de consolation
je pense
que si nous entrions dans un simple
processus d'adhésion nous en avons pour
une éternité c'est s'était il est
évident que l'ukraine ne présentent pas
du tout et caractéristiques requises
pour participer
administrativement institutionnellement
à une mécanique aussi complexe et
délicate que l'union européenne donc on
ne peut pas la laisser comme ça dans
l'incertitude pendant un nombre d'années
en revanche
il est tout à fait clair que sur le plan
politique nous avons peu il faut
associer très rapidement le cren en
d'autres termes je ne vois pas les
ukrainiens rentrer dans le business de
la commission etc je vois très bien le
président et linski présent au conseil
européen des chefs d'état et de
gouvernement donc il faut offrir ce
cadre politique subito comme disent les
les italiens tout de suite et en
revanche prendre le temps d'organiser
un
un rapprochement est une addition
éventuelle à l'union européenne ce qui
implique des modifications très
importante de l'union européenne elle
même on ne peut pas à système
institutionnel constant élargir
indéfiniment
or vous avez vu que quand on propose
comme la conférence pour l'avenir de
l'europe le fait quand on propose des
modifications institutionnelles
on a aussitôt très état qui disent nous
n'en voulons pas donc il faut éviter ce
blocage il faut contourner ce blocage et
il faut offrir tout de suite aux
ukrainiens une coopération politique
apparaît justement je ne vous parlez de
ça sur la révision des traités en scène
mâcon a plaidé pour une révision où il
était notamment la fin de l'unanimité
lundi vous dites très états membres s'y
sont déjà opposées sur 27 ça fait la
moitié ce que savard est un beau pays
écoutez il faut il faut bien voir que ce
qu'on appelle révision du traité et fans
l'unanimité ce sont des attitudes
d'ensemble en réalité quand vous
regardez l'article 48 du traité de
l'union européenne par lequel on
organise le changement vous avez trois
modes de modification et notamment vous
avez ce qu'on appelle la clause
passerelle qui est qui n'est pas une
révision des traités qui est simplement
la possibilité offerte aux états de
décider à l'unanimité qu'ils passeront à
la majorité qualifiée ces salles bc pas
c'est beaucoup plus léger qu'une
révision pure et simple et d'autre part
il s'agit pas de supprimer partout
l'unanimité mais de faire franchir une
étape importante par exemple en matière
de ressources propres en matière de
fiscalité
nous avons absolument besoin de sortir
de cette machine a tout bloqué quelle
unanimité donc il faut il faut
distinguer et puis si tout le monde
n'est pas d'accord il faut sans doute
combiné ça avec la coopération renforcée
et imaginer qu'on peut avoir des ddd des
zones de au sein de l'union européenne
par exemple les allemands les italiens
les néerlandais les français les
espagnols où on avance sur ces terrains
là à la majorité qualifiée même si on a
d'autres comme les polonais qui veulent
rester sur le bord de la route ce qu'ils
ont d'ailleurs tout à fait tort de faire
parler d'elle et julien un mot sur le
mali puisque les relations entre bamako
sont très tendues jean yves le drian
était convoqué par la justice malienne
pour une enquête sur pour atteinte aux
biens publics l'état major français a
publié des vidéos qui montrent des
paramilitaires de la ministre russe
wagner enterrant décor pour faire
accuser la france de crimes de guerre
est ce que vous êtes inquiet pour la
sécurité de nos soldats encore sur place
je suis inquiet je suis je trouve
désespérant manger un membre de ma
famille qui est mort
en opérations au mali la famille a
estimé que ce garçon avait payé le cher
sa vie mais que c'était justifié mais de
voir que ceux pour qui on est mort vous
traite comme ça c'est extrêmement
douloureux extrêmement douloureux le
vraiment le colonel keïta ne se
comportent pas d'une façon satisfaisante
nous nous étions mali parce que les
autorités maliennes qui n'est pas issu
d'un putsch nous l'avait demandé parce
que l'organisation des nations unies
nous l'avait demandé parce que la
communauté des états africains de
l'ouest nous l'avait demandé je suis
allé il ya quelques semaines j'ai fait
une petite tournée j'ai été voir le
président du niger qui nous d'y rester
nous avons besoin de la france pour
lutter contre le terrorisme
j'ai vu les autorités ivoiriennes qui
nous ont dit rester nous sommes nous
sommes inquiets la pénétration des demis
un mot terroriste dans le golfe de
guinée j'ai eu une longue conversation
avec le président du sénégal qui nous a
dit restez c'est très important que la
france assume ses responsabilités et
c'est donc nous ne sommes pas là
simplement parce que on aimerait en
afrique on est là parce que ça
correspond à un engagement profond de la
france qui est dédé maintenant ça pas
toujours été le cas d'aider les états
africains à vivre démocratiquement
leur liberté leur leur souveraineté et
là je dois dire que c'est cesser cette
manoeuvre absolument frauduleuse
horrifique enfin ils ont été pris la
main dans le sac immédiatement cesser
ces deux ça fait partie des faits qu
stratégie de la russie et ça c était
abominable je trouve que c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment très triste j'espère que
je ne sais pas où ils en sont
économiquement enfin la l'embargo qui
avait été créée par les pays africains
pose problème certainement aux autorités
sénégalaises autorités maliennes le
risque ce serait que se maintienne un
petit pouvoir autour du colonel keita à
bamako et que le reste du pays soit en
fait livré aux terroristes qui
contournerait bamako mais ce
avanceraient vers le sud vers le golfe
de guinée et ça c'est quand même quelque
chose de très préoccupant il ne faut pas
que l'afrique de l'ouest connaissent les
mêmes convulsions que l'afrique de l'est
avec cette épouvantable situation
entre le soudan l'ethiopie le tigre et
cetera il faut éviter cela c'est ce que
nous essayons de faire et je veux dire
tiens certain consensus se rappelle que
même monsieur mélenchon sur ce plan-là
avait tenu à l'assemblée nationale des
propos extrêmement nettes de solidarité
car mes française monsieur borlant je
vous parlais du jean luc mélenchon le
futur premier ministre dont je rigole
évidemment on est
inconnue
on est dans l'attenté imminente vous le
savez de l'annnonce du du gouvernement
quel profil idéal doit avoir le premier
ministre selon vous
écoutez je pense que il doit il doit
assumer je pense que c'est il ya une
part de continuité la continuité on voit
bien continuité macro nien c'est très
simple c'est les grands choix européens
libéraux et sociaux qui sont d'ailleurs
ceux l'udf antérieurement il faut le
dire bon ça joue avec mathieu mais en
même temps tout est nouveau la pandémie
la guerre d'ukraine
l'appel à
davantage de parité une participation
féminine au je crois qu'il faut que le
nouveau grenier miss répondent à ce
double exigence de continuité et de
renouvellement moi je ne sais pas quels
seront les jeux qu'il soit 2,2 de gauche
une majorité des français selon un
sondage récent appel à un premier
ministre de gauche écoutez je ne sais
pas ce que veut dire de gauche elle dort
à quoi ce qui me paraît caractéristique
c'est qu'il ya en france de gauche et de
droite il ya et nous sommes nous dans la
majorité nous représentons le centre
droit et le centre gauche c'est-à-dire
une gauche libérale qui acquit issu de
la révolution française la défense de la
liberté une gauche attachée au
multilatéralisme donc à la construction
européenne et à la sécurité collective
donc à l'alliance avec nono nos alliés
occidentaux
c'est le contraire de la gauche de
monsieur mélenchon qui est qui et
souverainistes en
antilibérale et extrêmement réservé
maintenant sur la laïcité donc là il ya
tout à fait possibilité d'avoir un
premier ministre qui effectivement 50
dans cette tradition libérale sociale
européenne
oui mais peut-être une question sur le
modem auquel vous appartenez alors vous
avez de le parti a reçu plus d'une
centaine d'investiture combien de sièges
pouvez vous espérer ans rien en moi vous
savez je crois que le seules personnes
qui peuvent répondre à vos questions à
votre question sont les électeurs nous
nous présentons nous avons un bilan qui
est très honorable
nous avons une ligne politique qui est
très claire et qui est à mon avis la
seule ligne qui représente vraiment un
avenir réaliste pour la france cette
ligne de développement de l'économie de
marché de maintien d'une de france
extrêmement solidaires et surtout de
construction d'une europe forte c'est
cette ligne là je pense que tant les
profondeurs du pays
cette ligne sera reconnue c'est le grand
enjeu on a véritablement pour la
première fois depuis nombreuses années
on a un choix qui est un choix sur des
valeurs absolument fondamentale est-ce
qu'on est pour cette solidarité
multilatérale est ce qu'on est pour
l'état de droit la démocratie
représentative est ce qu'on est pour une
économie de marché tempéré par la
puissance publique ou est-ce qu'on est
sur une toute autre ligne de rupture des
solidarités européenne de rupture des
solidarités atlantique de rupture avec
l'économie de marché là la réponse
appartient au peuple français faisons
lui confiance et ce sera un bon mot de
la fin merci beaucoup merci jean louis
bourlanges d'avoir était notre invité la
une de la voix du nord c'est la
sécheresse régnant sécheresse pour vu
quelqu'un c'est à la une de votre
journal merci julien
[Musique]